quit your job and go start it yes there
are characteristics for people who are
good at entrepreneurs they quit their
job and they go start it sit next to a
lovely woman once and she had a
fantastic idea for for a company and so
how long you been like designing it and
whatnot she said 18 months I said well
okay give you a bit of a bit of advice
you know like yeah put down your fork
and knife leave breakfast go to your
office lock the door thur your three
colleagues nobody's allowed to leave the
room you have to order in pizza and beer
and soda and whatever else is until you
finish the product dance life if you
don't do that you will never be
successful if you do it you have a shot
right you have a shot to fail which is
you know that's a that's a better
starting point then never even having a
shot to to fail so she didn't do it
somebody else along a couple other
companies launched the same problem she
actually never got out the out the door
so if you want to be an entrepreneur
quit your job right now shut down this
browser after you patronize big things
advertisers first and go start it now
why are you still looking at me go start
it now